so now all of a sudden in the wake of
the Trump Ukraine whistleblower Biden
scandal as we are sort of calling it
Democratic Speaker of the House Nancy
Pelosi is considering impeaching Donald
Trump there's a Washington Post report
very detailed that Nancy Pelosi up until
last night on the phone quietly sort of
feeling out House Democrats about
whether to start an impeachment inquiry
as a result of this most recent scandal
involving Donald Trump and Ukraine and
Joe Biden now to remind you my position
on this my position on unimpeached Minh
has been sort of neutral in the sense
that I'm fine doing it I'm fine not
doing it but a decision has to be made
and whether there is or isn't going to
be an impeachment inquiry Democrats need
to move forward on how to win in 2020
regardless of what the impeachment
decision is either use the impeachment
inquiry to try to win in 2020 or say
we're not doing the impeachment inquiry
and figure out how to win in 2020 anyway
now according to multiple senior House
Democrats and congressional aides Nancy
Pelosi is asking around
is this Ukraine thing the tipping point
making phone calls all day yesterday up
to last night and there's a key line
from this Washington Post report about
this story which is that there are now
many leadership aides who once thought
Donald Trump's impeachment was unlikely
who are now saying they believe it to be
almost inevitable remember that Nancy
Pelosi's previous position was Oh
impeachment will be too divisive so the
question is what has changed and what
has changed is the Ukraine story which
pulls together collusion bribery
geopolitical extortion suppression of
whistleblowers and this is extending
interest in impeachment reportedly
beyond just like the liberal base of
House Democrats to more centrist
Democrats as well Democrats are
admitting that the sort of tone and
tenor of conversations around
impeachment have changed since the
Ukraine story broke and although nothing
has been finalized it's important to
remember that even if an impeachment
inquiry did start it could take some
time which I don't think is bad I've
said
for the decision about the impeachment
inquiry should be made the timing of it
might be calculated to be more damaging
to Trump if it's delayed a little bit
until you know maybe early 2020 would be
the latest that I think it would make
sense to start it but then you also see
Democrats wasting time with certain
things around the Ukraine story here's
an example House Democrats are now
planning to hold a vote on a resolution
to maybe condemn Donald Trump's actions
in regard to this Ukraine Joe Biden
thing it's just a milquetoast irrelevant
thing I mean truly I get it you know you
get something on the record but the this
this it's just a waste you're not going
to do anything with that and the idea of
Ukraine as the tipping point if
international extortion of other
countries for the benefit of Donald
Trump's 2020 election chances by getting
Ukraine to smear Biden is not a tipping
point something is very wrong but we
already had many of what should have
been tipping points in the past already
the firing of the FBI director James
Comey Donald Trump's eight obstructive
acts Donald Trump supporting the Saudi
war on Yemen the financial crimes and
cover-ups I mean to say we are now at a
tipping point is accurate but it also
ignores that we've had a number of
tipping points already so what we get to
in the end is that Nancy Pelosi now
reconsidering impeachment it's just a
political calculation don't be tricked
into thinking that what Nancy Pelosi is
calculating is whether what Donald Trump
has done is bad enough to justify an
impeachment inquiry or impeachment
proceedings they want us to think that
they're evaluating whether what Trump
did is bad enough to justify impeachment
what they're really doing and what Nancy
Pelosi is doing is calculating whether
politically impeachment is likely to be
a successful move and when I say
successful I don't mean removing Trump
before the November 20 2011 trolling the
Senate
you're not going to remove Donald Trump
through impeachment the question is
would impeachment be successful in the
sense of being welcomed as the correct
move
by the public would it be potentially
beneficial for the 2020 election that is
what Nancy Pelosi is now considering and
I want to hear from you what do you
think I'm on Twitter at Dee Pakman the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
I've asked the before I've said before I
could go either way
on impeachment the question is what is
the right calculation to be making do
you believe the right calculation to be
making is a political one is it a moral
one is it a legal one let me know on
Twitter at Dee Pakman I will also be
streaming this evening on twitch at
twitch.tv slash David Pakman make sure
that you're following me there as well
today's program brought to you in part
by Blink accom slash Pakman blinkie's is
a great service that i use all the time
what they do is they take thousands of
the most popular non-fiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information and
insights from each book and I've
listened to a ton of books on blink as'
I recently checked out soccer na mcc's
by Simon Cooper we do have after all the
World Cup going on recently we also have
been talking about BS jobs and there is
a great new book of BS jobs by David
Graeber
which I listened to on blinka they're
constantly adding new books to the
platform you will never run out of
fascinating and critically acclaimed
books to enjoy and our audience can get
a seven day free trial by going to blink
is comm slash Pakman if you're watching
on YouTube I'm putting a link in the
video description and after the free
trial if you like it you can continue
enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
that's be Li NK is t.com /pa que mas